he said to me uh once he said you know
because
mom passed away i'm afraid you're going
to
and i said well it's a very different
thing john travolta opened up about a
difficult discussion he had with his son
ben following the death of his wife and
ben's mother kelly preston on the most
recent episode of heart to heart kevin
hart's new talk show an interview with
travolta turned to his personal
tragedies the actor revealed that his
son 10 year old ben expressed the fear
of john dying following kelly's death so
we're gonna keep you guys busy for the
next you know 20 years hey kelly died in
july 2020 following a two-year battle
with cancer she was 57. he said to me
once he said you know
because mom passed away i'm afraid
you're going to
and i said well it's a very different
thing and then i went through the
differences about my longevity and
in her limited life john went on to
reference the death of his son jed who
died following an accident in 2009 at
the age of 16. i said but you know ben
you always love the truth and i'm going
to tell you the truth about life nobody
knows when they're going to go
when they're going to stay i said your
brother left at 16.
too young
your mother left at 57. that was too
young
but who's to say i said i could die
tomorrow you could anybody can i said so
let's look at life
that
it's part of life
you see you you
you don't know
exactly you just do your best at trying
to live the longest you can in the year
since kelly's death john has frequently
paid tribute to his late wife on
instagram on mother's day john wrote
quote dearest kelly you brought into my
life three of the most wonderful
children i have ever known
thank you we love you and miss you john
has also been a girl dad on social media
for daughter ella in particular how the
21 year old actress is taking up the
family business i'm so excited to be
here amazing cast amazing crew i can't
wait to share it with you guys following
the news that ella was cast in a feature
adaptation of alice in wonderland john
took to instagram with praise he wrote
here's my daughter ella starring in a
live-action reimagining of alice in
wonderland called get lost i'm a very
proud dad meanwhile ella gushed over her
dad in a father's day tribute post
she wrote on instagram quote you make
parenting look so easy though it not
always is you make every day better than
the one before it you bring joy to us
when we are down you are our best friend
and we love you to the moon and back
around
i'm ridiculous
i'm behind the camera mouthing every
word she says back in 2019 john and ella
stopped by the talk where he admitted to
being a very hands-on parent my wife
kelly gets hysterical watching me watch
her
because i i just want it to go great
have the whole set vested and everything
he would come up in between scenes
because i was in a car so he would come
in here oh that was great oh my gosh
okay good